[Music]
rise and shine breakfast is ready in ten
minutes and don't make me come back up
there this is our town it's a close-knit
community a kind of place where everyone
knows everyone understood hey how are
you girls and we're always there for
each other nice sermon pastor well you
guys have on for the rest today
well dawn has a basketball game yeah
I've seen this guy whooping up around
here this kid is so rich text your mom
tomorrow until I win and where to pick
you up don't do anything stupid
[Applause]
Jimmy he's been underwater from 1 to 15
minutes it's gonna be a recovery little
rescue you've done everything medically
possible there's nothing more what you
do please God send their Holy Spirit
there's a must
[Music]
a fourteen-year-old st. Charles boy who
spent 15 minutes trapped underwater is
continuing to fight for his life
I don't believe John will survive the
night you don't know my son he is a
fighter so I need you to be the best for
John and you just let God do the rest
you are my pride and joy I can't wait to
see you those baskets and run up and
down again the Smith family asks for one
thing
please pray for John in the water that
day I was ready to give up but then I
hear this voice is telling me go back
either I'm nuts or God's talking to you
but I don't believe in God I believe but
maybe that only goes so far was
something like this I'm your pastor I'm
supposed to walk alongside you for as
long as it takes
did you see the Facebook page it's going
viral
call me hope is gonna be okay
we're not gonna get through this alone
whatever you have for me from time
[Music]